where we're trying to figure out the
right way to do it but we're gonna set
up a land party here what game nothing
fortnight it's at all you guys are doing
I think I think he will be addicted to
fortnight in underground more than
anyone you know if I think I have a
limited amount of time so we go right
back to quake what happens yeah but it's
but it's like then it's if you like
quake you'll love this quake champions
game this this quake online game looks
so crazy good and the fact that it's all
web-based now come on son
it's yeah went away sometime come on
over man [ __ ] some people up bring some
people into a room you would be a
championship gamer not wouldn't if you
if you got into things I mean if you got
into it you would be like one of the top
gamers you'd be the ninja no no I'm uh
not quite artistic enough to be at the
top of the food chain
just ask um I don't know who he is
you see the top guy when you say stop
he's one of my favorites to watch he got
yeah I think honestly that video games
are product at high levels especially
quake it's deceptively intellectually
challenging like when they have these
they would do a lot of these one on one
death matches and they would be in a
room and they would both spawn at the
same time then you have to run you have
to have knowledge of the map and you
also have to have knowledge of when
certain items are gonna respawn let me
steal the rocket launcher the another
rocket launcher will respawn and like I
forget how many seconds like 30 seconds
so they would run the map shoot the guy
collect the extra rocket launch before
he can keep him unarmed and keep killing
him over and over again and after you
kill him a certain amount of time the
game's over and the guys who are really
good at that were just they're just
really smart they're really smart really
fast twitch super tuned into the game
just like locked in and then they'd
study those maps and then they also
study like movement they could do crazy
[ __ ] like rocket jump on to people and
do things like that like get two areas
of the map just because they understood
how to hop they could do it in a way
that other people don't know how to do
that the kind engine he's talking about
is what you're describing so then the
game fortnight you have to build these
crazies just for it
you have to but you find mats with some
materials and you build forts so it
becomes these one-on-one matches if
you're playing solo where you have to
like literally build advantage you have
to gain advantage why is it why their
bricks are flying in the air he's
gaining the material so you're mining so
and then that becomes what you're
talking about you have to like either
you have only a couple guns you can
choose from so how did this build this
bridge here he's doing it that fast he's
he knows there's a guy over there and
he's going to attack right now
Wow and it's his decision on how he does
it though and that this map never
changes really they just sort of changed
break through the building to get in
there yeah you can break through and
then build it back up I got a problem
with this game adicted just watching
these diction is the colors to this game
has got some crazy colors which is like
yeah that crack for your brain yeah this
is amazing and it's weird cuz grown
adults just fallen in love with this
overnight well that's what I'm saying
like I was joking around about video
games that I'm not artistic enough I
think the best guys are going to be
considered like chess players I think
it's like kind of the same thing it's
just chess is traditionally worshipped
as this intellectual game right but I
think that a lot of video games like
Starcraft for sure is like this really
high level strategy game you're you're
doing things and you're thinking on
multiple levels about different parts of
the board and different things that
you're moving around it seems to me to
be like physically dynamic too because
things are moving quick like you you're
not you're not in control of what your
opponent is doing while he's doing it's
all happening in one time you're trying
to think your way through things and put
stuff here and move stuff there to this
we're under appreciate them because when
they first started out they were
frivolous like pong and stuff like that
- dude dude dude dude don't do do it do
it so we think of them as being dumb but
they're so sophisticated now and kids
are making [ __ ] [ __ ] loads of money
Dirk Lewis who was saying that he was
saying that your kid like you should
parents should probably encourage their
kids to play a games because there's
[ __ ] money in it now yeah right you
know Johnny Carson's old studio you've
been there probably a million times Jay
Leno's old studio it's now a blizzard
arena right
Street for me there's everyday
ready-to-go there ya go check it out I
would love to go to it's right down the
street for